όταν με πήρα αντηλέφωνο έτρεμε το χέρι μου ζουσα ένα όνιρο το κάναμε μετά ξεκίνησαν
κάποιες συνεργασίες το φύπερμερουπάμας ζωνα κυπα παρίζου στστέρ για κλυφάδας που τώρα δεν υπάρχουν μετική
τη γαρπί με τον νίκοβέρτη τ φόρται του μόλις κατέβηκε από τη θεσαλωνί και με
τοπίς τον μουξανάς το ποσιδόνειο η μια μηνε συνεχόμενα έκανα πολύ ώρες σην εργασίες από
και και πέρα όταν ερχόντους αν προτάσεις γιατί ήταν λογικό ημου να προετοημασμένος λίγο εμεί
στι κύ προ είμαστε λίγο πιο όχι πονήρι είμαστε λίγο πιο συνεσταλμένης της κοιμήσεις μας
και τότι κάνουμε πόσομάλλον ότι για μένα οι κίνηση και όλας μόνο εκίνηση τω να
είμαι αθήνα ήταν ένας άνθλος για να κύπριο να ξεσπιτωθεί να πάει χωρίς επανθελοχωρίς τίποτα
από το παιχνίδη θεωρώ ότιεκεί ξεκίνησαν ωραίς στιγμές μετέπειτα όταν ξεκίνησε να έρχεται η μια
πρόταση που δεν με καλύπτη άλλη που δεν με καλύπτ άλλη που ίναι λίγο βείτα
η άλλη που είναι λίγο αυτό πρωτημοσμηντα κάνωυ μου ήρθε μια σοβαρεί πρόταση στις νότες
από τη λεμεσώ να ηγηθώ του σκήματος που το είχα ανάγκη γιατί πέντεξη χρόνια εκεί
είχαν α πρόγραμματέκα είκος ητριάντα λεπτά και πίσω από τή κουρτίνα ανακούο τους τεράς τυς
καλυτέχρες που για μένα στην αρχή ήταν σχολίο αυτό το πράγμα κάποια στιγμή όμως πθεώρισ
ότι θέλω να κάνω λίγο το κάτι παραπάνω μου δόθηκε ευκαιρία εδώ μετά πήγα αυστεραλία
μετά ξανά εδώ τάξει με και νας άνθρωπος ο οποίος δε με εντιαφέρει ρα παιδί
μου α για να γίνω ο καλύτερος πρότοςσφεριστείς πρέει να παίζω στην αργεντινή στη βραζηλία
μου κάνει να παισλοκιστική προ φτάνει να έχω κοινόπου να μ αγαπά και να κάνω
αυτό που αγαπάω πέντε χρόνια στην αθήνα στη νυκτερηνήαθ υπάρχει ένα περιστατικό που θυμάσε που
ίσως και να συμφόβησε γιατί ηνύχτα